ambassadrice ambassadeur chez Robert
alors en effet depuis que le globe sec a
ouvert ses portes en 2008 de nombreux
dirigeants et responsables politiques
sont venus au Bratislava forum mais je
crois ça fera de ma part pas encore de
président français ce qui était sans
doute une incongruité
et ce serait plus encore aujourd'hui
alors que ce jour justement
avec la guerre
lancée par la Russie contre l'Ukraine
voisine tout simplement l'avenir de
notre continent et qui se joue aussi
pour beaucoup dans cette région et
d'autant que nous sommes aussi à l'orée
d'un mois qui résume l'ampleur de nos
enjeux stratégiques avec le sommet de la
communauté politique européenne demain à
kishina puis un Conseil européen
important pour l'avenir de notre union
au mois de juin et enfin le sommet de
l'OTAN à Vilnus et au fond avec ses
échéances je crois utile de vous livrer
avec beaucoup de liberté comment je vois
les choses du moment que vit notre
Europe sur le plan géopolitique
voilà presque 20 ans
notre union ouvrait ses portes à la
Slovaquie et à d'autres pays libérés de
l'emprise soviétique
ce n'était alors pas seulement un
élargissement de notre union c'était le
retour dans notre famille de ceux dont
nous avions été trop longtemps séparés
et je ne crois pas en effet qu'il y ait
une Europe occidentale et une Europe
orientale au fond une vieille Europe et
une Europe nouvelle ce serait perpétuer
la frontière artificielle imposée
pendant des décennies par l'Union
soviétique il n'y a qu'une Europe
d'une seule trame faite d'histoire mêlée
de diversité mais avec cette volonté
d'unité
géographique géopolitique et de bâtir au
fond un récit commun
et je crois que c'est ce qui nous réunit
tous d'ailleurs ce projet qui n'écrase
pas nos identités nationales et nos
projets nationaux mais nous permet de
les conjuguer dans un récit qui les
dépasse
rappelons-nous à cet égard les derniers
mots du directeur de l'agence de presse
de Hongrie quelques minutes avant d'être
écrasé par l'artillerie russe en
novembre 1956 nous mourrons pour la
Hongrie et pour l'Europe
le rideau tombé sur notre continent mais
c'était bien déjà l'unité de celui-ci
qui était en jeu
il annonçait des décennies d'éloignement
forcés des décennies d'occidents
d'occidents kidnappés pour reprendre la
belle formule de Milan Kundera que nous
pouvons faire notre aujourd'hui et
j'ajouterai à vous qui êtes ici
aujourd'hui que même après l'entrée de
la Slovaquie de beaucoup d'autres pays
dans l'Union nous n'avons pas toujours
assez entendu cette voix que vous
portiez qui appelait à reconnaître votre
histoire et vos mémoires douloureuses
d'aucun vous disait alors que vous
perdiez des occasions de garder le
silence je crois aussi que nous avons
parfois perdu des occasions d'écouter
ce temps
ce temps est révolu et aujourd'hui cette
voix doit être notre voie à tous alors
mon message est simple dans ce moment
que nous vivons nous ne devons pas
laisser l'Occident être kidnappé une
deuxième fois
nous ne laisserons pas l'Europe être
kidnappé une deuxième fois
alors les enjeux sont de taille quand la
guerre est un aux frontières
et en effet l'agression de l'Ukraine au
fond et la dernière manifestation la
manifestation extrême évidemment
de fragilité d'une contestation de notre
unité européenne qui sait jouer durant
ces 15 dernières années 15 années durant
lesquelles les tentatives de la Russie
pour bousculer tous l'édifice de
sécurité européenne et remodelés selon
ces termes celui-ci ce sont déployés
les étapes en sont connues le discours
de Vladimir Poutine à Munich de 2016
l'agression contre la Géorgie de 2008
contre l'Ukraine en 2014 contre
l'Ukraine encore en 2022 et la
vassalisation rampante de la Biélorussie
au fond ce que demande la Russie et
qu'elle avait codifié dans les projets
de traité brandy à la veille de son
invasion il y a un peu plus d'un an
c'est l'affaiblissement et la
neutralisation de l'Ukraine et au fond
la mise en vulnérabilité de toute une
partie de l'Europe en contrepartie
d'engagement
légers et largement un vérifiable
face à cela et il faut le reconnaître
nous n'avons pas su apporter une réponse
européenne
ni organiser une architecture qui nous
prémunissent via le SCE ou les autres
projets envisagés à l'époque contre ces
agressions
quant à la réponse de l'OTAN c'était au
fond trop ou trop peu une perspective
offerte à l'Ukraine et les Géorgie qui
exposaient ces deux pays à la
vaindictorus sans pour autant les
protéger et avec des garanties qui
étaient beaucoup trop faibles et nous
avons manqué de cohérence en tant que
européen nous avons apporté donc des
garanties insuffisantes à certains pays
qui étaient à nos frontières
nous n'avons pas engagé la Russie dans
un dialogue de sécurité pour nous-mêmes
et au fond nous avons délégué ce
dialogue à l'OTAN ce qui n'était pas
sans doute la meilleure le meilleur
moyen d'y arriver et dans le même temps
nous ne sommes pas sortis des
dépendances que nous avons plutôt
continuer de renforcer à l'égard de la
Russie en particulier en matière
énergétique et donc nous devons être
lucides sur nous-mêmes nous n'avons pas
été cohérent dans notre approche
en venant ici je sais qu'elle a été
l'expérience de nombreux d'entre vous
pendant la période soviétique et je sais
pourquoi avec raison chacun est
déterminé à ce que cela ne se reproduise
pas et c'est aussi mon engagement
tout pays a le droit de choisir ses
alliances et ce n'est jamais une menace
pour les voisins que d'opter pour la
liberté la démocratie la transparence
comme j'ai pu le vérifier avec force
avec les grands partenaires du G7 au
Japon il y a quelques jours
le fondement de la Charte des Nations
Unies demeure l'égalité souveraine et il
n'a jamais été la souveraineté limitée
et c'est à ce titre aussi que ce qui se
joue en Ukraine aujourd'hui n'est pas
simplement une question européenne mais
bien une question pour l'ordre
international et la paix partout dans le
monde
mais ce que montre la guerre en Ukraine
ce n'est pas seulement que ces
prétentions à mettre une partie de
l'Europe sous tutelle sont-ils légales
et inacceptables c'est aussi que vu du
raisonnement froid des rapports de force
elles sont désormais irréalistes
akief à cariffe à Kerson de vastes
armées russes ont reculées avant de se
consumer ensuite à barmut et ailleurs
pour des gains infimes
la guerre est loin d'être finie mais je
crois pouvoir dire aujourd'hui qu'une
chose est claire l'Ukraine ne sera pas
conquise
et d'ores et déjà ce qui était il y a un
peu plus d'un an une opération spéciale
ces soldée par un échec géopolitique à
date
qui s'est traduit par l'adhésion de la
Finlande et j'espère bientôt de la Suède
à l'OTAN et donc une fermeture de
l'accès à la Baltique pour la Russie
mais aussi par la défiance aggravée de
tous les voisins
par également une délégitimation de la
Russie dans le concert des nations
avec le non-respect de la Charte la
situation sur le terrain ne donne aucune
crédibilité à la Russie pour exiger par
la menace ce qu'aucun droit déjà ne
justifié et donc il n'y a pas de place
en Europe pour un fantasme impérial
c'est très important de le reconnaître
et cela conditionne à mes yeux tout
organisation future de la paix
alors la manière dont nous sommes
arrivés là dit plusieurs choses de nous
il faut les retenir pour essayer de
bâtir l'avenir la première c'est la
force de notre alliance dès les premiers
jours du conflit le temps a assuré la
sécurité de ses frontières avec beaucoup
d'efficacité l'article 5 a joué tout son
rôle et je suis convaincu qu'il tient
aussi la Russie en respect et nous
devons à cet égard être reconnaissant à
nos alliés américains qui ont fourni une
part majeure du soutien en équipement et
en renseignement à l'Ukraine
j'avais en décembre 2019 une phrase
sévère à l'égard de l'OTAN soulignant à
l'époque je vous le rappelle les
divisions qui existaient en son sein
entre la Turquie et plusieurs autres
puissances en parlant de mort cérébrale
je pourrais dire aujourd'hui que
Vladimir Poutine l'a réveillé avec le
pire des électrochocs
la deuxième chose qui me frappe c'est le
rôle exemplaire aussi de l'Union
européenne
nous avons été unis rapide et clair et
je crois que très peu a commencé par la
Russie s'attendait à ce que l'Union
européenne puisse réagir ainsi
67 milliards d'aide d'euros d'aide au
total donc 14 milliards d'euros d'aide
militaires
des sanctions de l'aide d'urgence
l'accueil de millions de réfugiés
une réorganisation complète et profonde
en quelques mois de notre organisation
énergétique qui était très dépendante de
la Russie et donc ça a été un
démonstration d'unité de clarification
stratégique sous la contrainte elle
aurait dû être faite avant mais on doit
s'en satisfaire et aussi l'adoption
d'une clarté de doctrine dont je me
félicite l'Europe a choisi l'autonomie
stratégique et la souveraineté
européenne et l'agenda de Versailles que
nous définissons dès mars 2022
au fond et bien loin de ce que certains
qualifiés il y a 5 ans de lubies
françaises lorsqu'elle a la Sorbonne je
parlais de souveraineté européenne
et donc je crois que la deuxième chose
aux côtés de la force de l'alliance que
nous devons retenir de ces derniers mois
ça a été l'unité la clarification
idéologique de notre Union européenne et
aussi sa clarté en termes de soutien
militaire humanitaire économique à
l'égard de l'Ukraine la France a
pleinement joué son nom rôle à cet égard
je pourrais y revenir dans les questions
et j'y reviendrai aussi dans les
prochaines semaines et les prochains
mois
cependant tout cet effort collectif ne
vaut que s'il s'inscrit dans la durée
et quand je regarde maintenant devant
fort de ce que je viens de dire de
l'analyse du passé de la situation des
derniers mois je voudrais essayer de
dessiner notre avenir
la tentation est certainement grande à
Moscou d'espérer que là où les armées
n'ont pas réussi le temps viendra aider
en supplétif la Russie à la faveur de
telle ou telle élection ou de tel ou
telle lassitude des opinions
je pense qu'il nous faut être très clair
sur ce qui nous revient de faire à court
et moyen terme
il nous faut aujourd'hui
aider le crâne par tous les moyens pour
mener une contre-offensive efficace
c'est un indispensable
c'est ce que nous sommes en train de
faire nous devons l'intensifier car ce
qui se joue dans les prochains mois
c'est la possibilité même d'une paix
choisie et donc durable la deuxième
chose c'est que nous devons être très
clair sur ce qu'on appelle la paix
la paix en Ukraine est sur notre
continent ça ne peut pas être un cesser
le feu qui consacre l'état de fête qui
reviendrait à recréer un conflit gelé et
qui en quelque sorte viendrait consacrer
la prise de territoire contrevenant à
tous les principes de droit
international parce que au fond ce
conflit gelé ce serait la guerre à coup
sûr demain ou après-demain et notre
affaiblissement à tous
il n'y a qu'une paix celle qui respecte
le droit international qui est choisi
par celui qui est agressé c'est-à-dire
le peuple craignant et qui est une paix
qui puisse être durable et qui donc
respecte ses équilibres
avec également et j'y reviendrai des
garanties crédibles
et donc il nous faut nous préparer
à ce que ce conflit dur est-ce que les
conséquences de ce configure avec
beaucoup de lucidité
j'espère que les prochains mois
permettront après une contre-offensive
victorieuse de remettre tout le monde
autour de la table et de bâtir une paix
durable aux conditions que je viens de
préciser choisi par l'Ukraine et
respectant le droit international mais
nous aurons nous le savons encore des
années et des années de reconstruction
de situations humanitaires à gérer mais
nous devons aussi pour être crédible
vis-à-vis de la Russie nous mettre en
situation nous nos opinions publiques
de soutenir dans la durée
l'Ukraine dans un conflit de haute et
moyenne intensité
et pour cela il nous faudra avec
l'ensemble de nos partenaires
revoir et ré-analyser durant l'été la
nature justement de notre soutien et ce
qu'il faut pour pouvoir aboutir aux
résultats que j'évoquais dans le même
temps il nous faut convaincre le sud
parce que nous avons dans le contexte
que j'évoquais une fragilité sur
laquelle il faut être lucide c'est
qu'aujourd'hui si grâce à l'engagement
du Japon et de quelques autres
cette guerre n'est pas simplement celle
de l'Occident
et bien beaucoup de puissance
émergentes considèrent que ça n'est pas
leur guerre
quand bien même il reconnaisse que c'est
une agression et qu'elle ne
respecte pas la Charte des Nations Unies
il le marmonne à peine entre leurs
lèvres
parce qu'il considère que leur
principaux problèmes sont de lutter
contre la pauvreté dans leur pays qu'on
leur a mis suffisamment de contraintes
qu'il y a des doubles standards et qu'on
ne sait pas occuper de leur propre
sécurité il y a d'autres temps et qu'il
vivent à plein les conséquences de cette
guerre là où quand eux-mêmes étaient
menacé dans leur sécurité nous n'avons
pas réagi avec la même vigueur nous
devons entendre ce message
le risque sinon étant que tous ces pays
soient récupérés
par d'autres pour bâtir un ordre
international alternatif
et deviennent
de manière choisie lucide ou de fait par
des effets de composition des alliés
objectifs dans la durée d'un chemin
russe et donc il nous faut absolument
dans le même temps que nous produisons
les efforts de soutien la préparation de
la paix durable faire ce travail de
conviction à l'égard des pays du Sud et
de plusieurs émergents et donc aussi
nous réengager dans l'aide que nous
devons leur apporter dans la
clarification de notre agenda
maintenant une fois que je vous ai dit
tout cela regardant notre avenir
la question qui nous est posée
est de savoir qu'elle est dans la durée
au fond pour notre Europe
l'avenir possible
et comment notre Europe peut
rebâtir une paix une sécurité une
stabilité durable pour elle-même
nous avons très bien réagi à court terme
les états par leur engagement l'ont
montré l'OTAN a montré sa crédibilité à
son flanc Est
et l'Union européenne par son engagement
mais insuffisant dans la durée
nous devons aujourd'hui nous féliciter
d'avoir une administration américaine
qui s'est engagée à nos côtés qui a
fourni autant d'efforts que les
Européens mais qui accroît très
clairement notre crédibilité collectif
soyons reconnaissants et remerciants les
États-Unis d'Amérique
est-ce que cette administration sera la
même pour toujours
nul ne sait le dire et nous ne pouvons
déléguer notre sécurité collective et
notre stabilité
au choix des électeurs américains dans
les années qui viennent
dans le même temps les mêmes américains
nous demandent depuis des années quel
que soit les administrations de partager
mieux le fardeau de nous occuper
davantage de notre sécurité de notre
voisinage et c'est donc en cela
que oui une Europe de la défense un
pilier européen au sein de l'OTAN est
indispensable c'est le seul moyen d'être
crédible pour nous-mêmes d'être crédible
dans la durée de réduire nos dépendances
et de prendre cette part légitime du
fardeau qui est le nôtre parce que qu'on
le veuille ou non notre géographie ne
changera pas
nous habiterons la même place et la
Russie restera la Russie avec les mêmes
frontières et la même géographie et il
nous faut nous bâtir un espace qui
demain devra être cet espace de paix
durable parce que le peuple craignant
aura été respecté dans ses droits et le
droit international rétabli mais qui
nous permettent de cohabiter de la
manière la plus pacifique sans naïveté
aucune avec la Russie de demain
je le redis il ne s'agit dans ce projet
n'est d'avoir de la naïveté à l'égard de
la Russie je n'en ai jamais eu mais
enfin de ne pas nier la géographie et de
ne pas considérer que nos choix
devraient être
comme si nous vivions avec un océan
entre la Russie et nous
et objectif n'est nullement d'essayer de
remplacer l'OTAN par autre chose et je
veux ici écarter tous les fantasmes
parce que je sais combien ils peuvent
être
répétés déformé je ne veux pas remplacer
le temps par une forme de condominium
franco-allemand non je pense que c'est
une Europe large puissante avec des pays
comme le vôtre comme la Pologne et
beaucoup d'autres qui doivent prendre
leur part dans cette Europe de la
défense mais qui assume sa propre
sécurité de manière croissante et ces
questions de voisinage
alors pour ce faire il nous faut
maintenant dans l'urgence procéder à une
forme d'accélération de nos choix
stratégiques et de la mise en oeuvre de
nous avons commencé à décider et c'est
un peu cet agenda qu'il nous faut bâtir
pour construire ce destin commun d'abord
il nous faut construire une capacité
européenne plus souveraine en matière
énergétique technologique et militaire
c'est un peu l'agenda que nous avons
assis à Versailles en mars 2022
maintenant il faut le mettre en œuvre
de manière accélérée très concrète c'est
à dire construire européen acheter
européen innovés européens de plus en
plus
sur le plan militaire c'est aussi ça
qu'il nous faut faire avec un effort
national que nous devons produire la
France n'a pas attendu cette guerre nous
avons accru notre effort dès la loi de
programmation portée sous mon premier
mandat et nous sommes en train de la
croix de 100 milliards d'euros par
rapport à la période précédente pour
atteindre un total de 413 milliards
d'euros
avec la loi de programmation qui se
porte mais avec l'horizon des 2% du PIB
nous devons aussi adjoindre des
objectifs concrets des déploiements des
capacités réelles qui crédibilis cet
effort collectif comme par exemple la
France l'a fait quelques jours après
l'un l'agression russe en Ukraine en
déployant des forces en Roumanie moins
de huit jours après nous avions des
centaines de soldats en Roumanie c'est
la crédibilité d'une Europe de la
défense dans le cadre de l'OTAN mais il
faut un choix souverain des capacités
des dépenses et une capacité
d'engagement
cette autonomie stratégique cette
souveraineté militaire c'est aussi un
effort industriel nous avons bien
compris ces derniers mois en vidant nos
arsenaux que nous ne possédions avec
certitude que ce que nous produisons
nous devons en tirer les conséquences et
quand je vois certains pays qui
accroissent leurs dépenses de défense
pour acheter massivement du non européen
j'ai leur dit simplement vous préparer
vos problèmes de demain
il nous faut utiliser ce moment pour
produire davantage en européen nous
avons su faire ensemble
une invention produire quelque chose de
nouveau sur les munitions
formidable avancée pour aider le crâne
nous devons aller beaucoup plus loin
nous devons harmoniser nos standards
européens parce que nous faisons trop de
concurrence entre nous il y a beaucoup
plus de standards entre européen qui en
a aux États-Unis d'Amérique mais ce
faisant nous devons développer une base
industrielle
technologique de défense vraiment
européenne
dans tous les pays qui sont intéressés
et déployer des équipements pleinement
souverains sur le plan européen il nous
faut réduire en effet nos dépendances et
il nous faut continuer de construire une
intimité stratégique pour cet effort
collectif
je pense évidemment à l'initiative
européenne d'intervention que nous avons
lancé il y a 5 ans et qui garde toute sa
pertinence aujourd'hui plusieurs d'entre
vous sont venus avec nous lutter contre
le terrorisme en Afrique montrant que la
solidarité oeuvre dans les deux sens et
je leur ensegrai et même si la présence
française en Afrique change la nécessité
de continuer à être engagé ensemble
demeure et donc il faudra réfléchir à
des coopérations possibles dans tous ces
espaces mais bâtir des capacités entre
européen en s'appuyant sur
l'interopérabilité de l'OTAN mais en
allant au-delà en sachant engagé
ensemble des forces d'action communes
sur des théâtres d'opérations nouveaux
dans nos voisinages mais également dans
le cyber dans l'espace dans le maritime
etc
plus largement vous le voyez ce premier
pilier qui est au fond de renforcer
notre souveraineté militaire c'est de se
dire regardons où nous vivons
c'est à nous européen dans l'avenir
d'avoir notre propre capacité à nous
défendre et à gérer nos voisinage
et à ce titre nous nous précipitons pas
forcément
dans les capacités pour gérer les
guerres d'hier ou d'aujourd'hui
ou pour gérer les conflits qui sont
simplement ceux qui apparaissent
aujourd'hui gérer notre voisinage ce
n'est pas simplement notre flan oriental
c'est la Méditerranée Méditerranée
orientale et Méditerranée du Sud et ce
sont les nouveaux espaces de
conflictualité
le cyber le spatial et le maritime et
ils sont au moins aussi importants que
des guerres continentales terrestres
qu'on a vu ressurgir
à cause de l'agression russe et
compenser voir disparaître mais qui
n'enlève pas les nouvelles formes de
conflictualité qui vont être croissantes
donc ayons aussi cette lucidité
stratégique pour préparer les conflits
d'avenir qui ne manqueront pas d'arriver
au-delà de cet axe de souveraineté donc
européenne technologique et militaire de
deuxième défi c'est de faire que
l'Europe au lieu de subir les évolutions
stratégiques de son environnement en
deviennent l'actrice de plein droit
j'ai été frappé et moi ces dernières
années devoir au fond que
nous n'étions pas sortis de l'état de
minorité géopolitique nous européens
c'est très dur pour un président de
français de dire ça de manière aussi
crue ça produit de l'énervement de la
contrariété mais moi j'ai connu cette
expérience d'arriver un sommet de l'OTAN
avec une autre administration européenne
qui nous notre administration pardon
américaine qui nous aimait moins mais
qui en nous le notifiant à peine et
encore donnant de manière très
bureaucratique les choses avec les
Européens nous a notifié l'arrêter avec
le traité FNI en disant les Russes ne le
respectent plus l'année 2019 nous
européens nous avons découvert que un
traité qui nous couvrait
face à des missiles qui touchaient notre
sol
le non-respérus et la décision
américaine pouvait nous laisser nu parce
que nous n'étions pas partir à celui-ci
de la même manière lorsque la Russie
prend méthodiquement dégage et suspend
l'application du traité newstart en
février dernier puis contrevient
clairement à l'acte fondateur autant
Russie en mars etc etc
je le dis très clairement nous européens
nous devons être les acteurs de ces
traités qui couvrent notre sécurité
et qui construisent le cadre à venir
si nous le délégons à d'autres la Russie
les États-Unis d'Amérique ou que sais-je
nous serons jamais des acteurs crédibles
et donc oui nous devons construire ces
solutions diplomatiques d'avenir pour ce
faire il nous faut d'abord
maîtriser pleinement les armements ce
qui revient avec ce que je disais sur
notre lucidité industrielle
l'Europe a été absente des traités comme
le traité sur les forces nucléaires
intermédiaires ou le traité new start
alors que sa sécurité était en jeu pour
celles doit peser et donc elle le fera
avec d'autant plus de crédibilité
qu'elle sera actrice et non spectatrice
de ses équilibres c'est pourquoi j'ai
appelé les Européens à se doter d'une
capacité de frappe dans la profondeur
qui renforcera notre sécurité et qui
nous donnera également un atout pour
toutes les négociations futures et je
souhaite donc lancer des discussions
avec les partenaires européens qui
seront intéressés pour explorer une
coopération dans ce domaine
le second qui est lié celui de la
défense anti-aérienne
la guerre en Ukraine a montré son
importance vitale c'est un sujet
stratégique avant d'être un sujet de
capacité industrielle mais
très clairement il doit reposer sur un
équilibre d'action offensive et d'action
défensive il doit prendre en compte
clairement la dissuasion nucléaire et
c'est pourquoi comme je m'y étais engagé
à muni qu'une conférence sur ce sujet
sera organisée à Paris le 19 juin j'y
invite tous les ministres de la Défense
des pays européens ici représentés à s'y
rendre et ne nous permettra de
poursuivre ensuite le travail et le
troisième c'est plus largement la
manière pour l'Europe de sécuriser son
environnement nous devons en effet bâtir
ces nouveaux traités en étant pleinement
acteur et autour de la table et pour
cela soyons très clair la question
de la sécurité à notre voisinage va se
poser nous y reviendrons sans doute dans
les questions
mais la sécurisation de notre
environnement est un élément clé de
cette crédibilité et d'une Europe
pleinement actrice nous devrons apporter
à l'Ukraine des garanties de sécurité
solides pour marquer un coup d'arrêt au
déstabilisation à répétition et si la
Russie persiste à vouloir déstabiliser
l'Europe elle doit être prête à en payer
le prix géopolitique j'entends tous les
débats que nous avons
mais nous serions d'étranges acteurs
géopolitiques à dire nous armons
massivement
le crâne
mais nous ne voulons l'inclure dans
aucun débat stratégique de sécurité
je lisais Henri Kissinger qui n'est pas
le diplomate le moins expérimenté il
avait raison de dire
en un an tous ceux qui a bon droit ont
été l'Ukraine on en fait un acteur
tellement puissant et qu'il vaut mieux
le ré inclure
dans ces architectures de sécurité
existantes et je crois partager plutôt
cette vision
et donc si nous voulons une paix
crédible durable si nous voulons peser
face à la Russie si nous voulons être
crédible vis-à-vis des Ukrainiens
nous devons donner à l'Ukraine les
moyens d'empêcher toute nouvelle
agression
et nous devons inclure l'Ukraine
dans un ensemble et une architecture de
sécurité crédible y compris pour
nous-mêmes c'est pourquoi je suis
favorable et ce sera l'objet des
discussions collectives dans les
prochaines semaines d'ici au sommet de
Vilnius mais de donner des garanties de
sécurité tangibles et crédible à
l'Ukraine pour deux raisons
le crâne aujourd'hui protège l'Europe
elle apporte des garanties de sécurité à
l'Europe de faite et la deuxième raison
c'est que l'Ukraine aujourd'hui est
dotée de tellement d'armements que c'est
notre intérêt qu'elle est des garanties
de sécurité crédibles avec nous dans un
cadre multilatéral avec soit des
soutiens multilatéraux soit des soutiens
bilatéraux c'est ce que nous aurons à
discuter il nous faut être beaucoup plus
ambitieux que nous ne le sommes parfois
dans les discussions aujourd'hui sur ce
sujet
à plus moyen terme c'est évidemment la
stabilité de notre Europe et ça sécurité
qui nous faudra bâtir sur la base de
cette paix solide en Ukraine de ces
garanties de sécurité à notre voisinage
et la question demain de la Biélorussie
et d'autres se posera et d'un cadre
transparent de confiance
permettant d'assurer enfin d'éviter une
escalade des capacités dans l'avenir
pour un moment sortir de cet état de
guerre quand la paix sera négociée
et stable
or nous avons tellement sur armé notre
flanc Est et la Russie engagé un tel
armement qui nous faudra reconstruire et
je parle là du moyen terme un cadre de
désescalades mais ce sera à ce moment-là
aux Européens de le construire vraiment
dans un cadre transparent où nous
devrons être acteurs de ces traités
autour de la table pour négocier et
autour de la table pour juger de leur
bon respect et de leur évolution
contrairement à ce que nous avions fait
par le passé c'est pourquoi dans ce
cadre
nous devons aussi penser une Europe plus
large et je conclurai mes propos sur ces
points cette Europe large c'est celle
que j'ai voulu proposer il y a un peu
plus d'un an à Strasbourg celle de la
communauté politique européenne pourquoi
parce que il nous faut penser notre
Europe pas simplement d'un point de vue
sécurité dans le cadre de l'OTAN et pas
simplement dans le cadre de l'Union
européenne c'est pourquoi la communauté
politique européenne n'est ni un
concurrent l'OTAN ni un substitut à
l'élargissement mais elle est un cadre
de discussion stratégique dont
l'ensemble des pays ont besoin pour
bâtir je l'espère une architecture
institutionnelle innovante et nouvelle
mais en matière d'énergie
d'interconnexion de mobilité de sécurité
de stratégie construire des solutions
communes sans attendre le parachèvement
de l'élargissement et sans se réduire à
une approche sotanienne nous le
poursuivrons donc demain
et nous dirons notre volonté d'aller
aussi loin que possible dans ce format
qui permet je le crois à une discussion
apaisée et de faire émerger des sujets
d'intérêt commun en particulier j'aurai
l'occasion d'y proposer l'extension de
la cyber réserve européenne à l'ensemble
des pays de la CPE parce que c'est notre
intérêt d'être solidaire pour préserver
notre sécurité
à cet égard la communauté politique
européenne est un laboratoire
géopolitique je crois pouvoir le dire il
nous faut poursuivre en ce sens mais
comme je le disais ça n'est pas un
substitut à l'élargissement
et la question pour nous et je conclurai
sur ce point elle n'est pas de savoir si
nous devons élargir nous avons répondu
il y a un an ni même quand nous devons
le faire c'est pour moi le plus vite
possible mais bien comment nous devons
le faire plusieurs s'en souviennent la
France avait porté le changement de la
méthode d'élargissement en 2018
mais au fond la guerre en Ukraine et la
situation aujourd'hui qui se dégrade
dans plusieurs zones des Balkans
occidentaux nous montre une chose c'est
que notre méthode actuelle ne marche pas
alors je pense qu'il y a deux erreurs
qui nous faut éviter
la première erreur ce serait de se dire
la situation se dégrade
restons comme on est et au fond deux
noms des espoirs au balcon occidentaux à
l'Ukraine à la Moldavie et jouons avec
le temps on sait très bien faire ce
sport on l'a longtemps pratiqué
si nous faisons ça
je pense que de fait nous donnerons plus
d'espace à tous ceux qui veulent
déstabiliser l'Europe en son sein
et je pense que nous nous réveillerons
dans quelques années avec une situation
qui se sera largement dégradée largement
dégradé
il y a une deuxième erreur qui serait de
dire élargissons c'est notre devoir
notre intérêt géopolitique parce qu'il
faut ancrer la Moldavie l'Ukraine les
Balkans occidentaux dans notre Europe
allons-y
on verra après pour réformer
ce serait une catastrophe aussi parce
que ce serait une Europe impuissante
faite de ces lourdeurs
parfois trop bureaucratiques de sa
lenteur et surtout d'une norme
divergence
c'est que vous voyez bien qu'en Europe
il y a au fond de force profonde les
deux se respectent
celle qui consiste à dire on a besoin de
plus d'unités géopolitiques d'ancrer les
Balkans occidentaux la Moldavie
l'Ukraine dans cette Europe elle doit
être unie elle doit se penser dans cet
espace sur le plan de la sécurité de la
géopolitique de l'énergie des migrations
et de l'autre côté on a une orque qui
dit mais on a besoin d'intégrer
davantage les politiques économiques
d'avoir encore plus d'exigences sur
l'état de droit
et elle crée en quelque sorte une
centralité qui est parfois rejetée par
certains états
il nous faut penser ce paradoxe c'est
que notre Union européenne n'a pas été
pensé pour s'élargir à Newton jusqu'à
ses frontières elle a été pensée pour
toujours s'approfondir davantage et elle
est vers un projet de plus en plus
intégré il nous faut donc c'est le
moment que nous vivons et tout arrive un
peu ensemble mais c'est comme ça
un très grand moment de clarification
théorique et géopolitique de notre Union
européenne oui elle doit s'élargir oui
elle doit être repensée dans sa
gouvernance très profondément et dans
ses finalités oui elle doit innover sans
doute pour inventer plusieurs formats et
clarifier les finalités de chacun de ces
formats c'est le seul moyen de répondre
à l'attente légitime des Balkans
occidentaux de la Moldavie et de
l'Ukraine qui doivent rentrer dans
l'Union européenne et de garder une
efficacité géopolitique mais aussi en
matière de climat d'État de droit
d'intégration économique de l'Union
européenne telle qu'elle vit aujourd'hui
et donc il nous faut aussi réarticuler
repenser le couple intergouvernemental
et politique communautaire et savoir
comprendre également ce qui ressort de
plusieurs États membres lorsque il ne
comprennent plus l'Europe telle que
chemin
ce moment et pour maintenant et nous
aurons à y travailler avec plusieurs de
nos partenaires dans les semaines à
venir j'ai déjà été trop long pardon
président et Mesdames et Messieurs mais
voilà quelques-uns des points que je
voulais évoquer et donc au fond vous
l'avez compris
ce jour notre capacité à bâtir une paix
juste et durable en Ukraine sans aucune
faiblesse mais se joue également
l'avenir de notre continent je le crois
très profondément dans les mois
et les deux trois ans qui viennent
pas beaucoup plus
je crois que le réveil conceptuel et
stratégique l'Europe l'a vécu mais il
faut qu'elle aille au bout des
conséquences à en tirer pour elle-même
et son voisinage dans ce cadre je crois
que vous l'avez compris ma présence veut
dire cela
vous pouvez compter sur la France elle a
parfois été perçue comme arrogante où
l'antenne ou ne s'intéressant pas à
cette partie de l'Europe pour ma part
durant mon premier mandat j'ai visité
chaque pays membres de l'Union
européenne chacun parce que je considère
que l'Union européenne ça n'est pas
simplement Bruxelles c'est l'ensemble
des capitales et c'est ce dialogue
toujours plus rien et c'est l'absence
d'hégémonie
mais vous pourrez dans la durée compter
sur la France mais je sais aussi que la
France pourra compter sur vous tous pour
que nous bâtissions ensemble une Europe
plus forte plus souveraine plus capable
d'assurer sa sécurité et on ne le fera
pas à 1 à 2 ou à 3
on le fera à 27 et même davantage en
incluant dans ce débat stratégique tous
ceux qui seront demain avec nous à
kishina dans cette capacité à avoir un
dialogue franc ouvert large puissant
ambitieux en acceptant nos différences
en les respectant et en clarifiant nos
finalités au fond
assumons ensemble ce que notre Europe
doit être une grande puissance
démocratique
diverses mais unis merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]